I love that they're an activists
generation they're not just hashtagging
their discontent they're arranging
rallies and they're actually showing up
they're coming of age right now and
they're coming of age in a time of
stress in the world they're seeing
tension in their own countries
political divides that we have never
seen before and this is forming their
worldview I think some of the
liabilities that their generation has to
face and has to deal with is that we are
seeing increasing rates of addiction to
social media and suicide depression
anxiety and we're letting young people
grow up and just hoping that it works
out but why not teach them why not guide
how to interact with other human beings
what's appropriate and what's
inappropriate we can take responsibility
for teaching some of these skills
[Music]
you